after spending 90 million dollars warner
brothers have made the shocking reveal
that their batgirl film has been
scrapped the film was set to star singer
and actress leslie grace who is best
known for her role as nina rosario in
the film adaptation of in the heights in
a statement for the hollywood reporter a
spokesperson for warner brothers
explains that the decision to not
release batgirl reflects our
leadership's strategic shift as it
relates to the dc universe and hbo max
leslie grace is an incredibly talented
actor and this decision is not a
reflection of her performance
reflecting on the news herself leslie
grace took to her instagram to thank
fans for their support stating on the
heels of the recent news about our movie
batgirl i am proud of the love hard work
and intention all of our incredible cast
and tireless crew put into this film to
every batgirl fan thank you for the love
and belief allowing me to take on the
cape hashtag batgirl
for life i know i'm not the only person
perplexed and confused by this news and
it's a shame like i was really excited
to see this version of batgirl on the
big screen now while this news comes as
a big shock to dc fans marvel fans got a
surprise of their own a good one
yesterday when it was revealed that a
rupaul's drag race queen would be
joining the mcu deadline reports that
all star's five winner shay coulee will
be joining marvel's disney plus series
ironheart in an unknown role it's gonna
be iconic the drag superstar took to her
socials to express her gratitude saying
beyond excited to be strutting out of
the work room right into the marvel
cinematic universe words cannot express
how excited i am to be a part of this
amazing project acting was my first love
and i'm thrilled to be doing it again in
such a big way
you